قطاع العملات المشفره في بريطانيا يختنق
رغم محاولات انعاشه من طرف حكومه رئيس
الوزراء ريشيسوناك فجهود الاخير في جعل
البلاد مركزا عالميا للعملات المشفره
اصطدمت بتعنت واضح من البنوك الكبرى في
بريطانيا فنقلا عن موقع فان العديد من
البنوك البريطانيه الكبرى فرضت مزيدا من
القيود على مقدار الاموال التي يمكن
للعملاء تحويلها الى بورصات الاصول
الرقميه كما ترفض هذه البنوك انشاء حساب
المصرفي للشركات الناشئه في قطاع التشفير
وتحتاج هذه الشركات الناشئه الى البنوك
التقليديه في معاملاتها بشكل عام سواء
لانشاء حسابات بنكيه او لمبادله العمله
الورقيه باصول رقميه ودفع سوق الخدمات
المصرفيه بعض الشركات قطاع التشفير الى
التقدم بشكوى مباشره الى حكومه سوناك هذا
وتراجع راس المال للاستثماري في شركات
الاصول الرقميه في المملكه المتحده بنسبه
94% مقارنه بالعام السابق